what do you think about the
whistleblower francis
hoggin recently coming out and saying
that facebook is aware for instagram's
harmful effect on teenage girls
um as per their own internal research
studies and the matter what do you think
about this
baby of yours instagram being under fire
now as we've been talking about
under the leadership of facebook
you know i often question
where does the blame lie
is the blame at the people
that originated the network me
right
uh is the blame
at like the decision to combine the
network with
another network with a certain set of
values
um is the blame
at how it
gets run after i left like is is it the
driver or is it the car
right um
is it that someone enabled these devices
in the first place if you go to an
extreme right
or is it the
users themselves just human nature is it
is it just the way of human nature sure
and like the idea that we're gonna find
a mutually exclusive answer here is
crazy there's not one place it's a
combination of a lot of these things
and then the question is like is it true
at all right like i'm not actually
saying that's not true or that it's true
but
there's always more nuance here
do i believe that social media um has an
effect on young people well it's got it
they use it a lot
and i bet you there are a lot of
positive effects and i bet you there are
negative effects just like any
technology
and where i've come to in my thinking on
this is that i think any technology has
negative side effects the question is
as a leader what do you do about them
and are you actively working on them or
do you just like not really believe in
them
if you're a leader that sits there and
says well we're going to put an enormous
amount of resources against this
we're going to acknowledge when there
are
true criticisms we're going to be
vulnerable that we're not perfect
and we're going gonna go fix them and
we're gonna be held accountable along
the way
i think that people generally really
respect that um
but i think that where facebook i think
has had issues in the past is where they
say things like
i can't remember what mark said about
misinformation during the election there
was that like famous quote where he was
like
it's pretty crazy to think that facebook
had anything to do with this election
like that was something like that quote
and i don't remember what stage he was
on and yeah yeah
but ooh that did not age well right like
you have to be willing to say well maybe
there's there's there's something there
and and wow like i want to go look into
it and and truly believe it in your gut
but if people look at you and how you
act and what you say and don't believe
you truly feel that way
it's not just the words you say about
how you say them and that people believe
that you actually feel the pain of
having caused any suffering so to me
it's um it's much more about your
actions
and your posture post event than it is
about debugging the why because i don't
know is it
like i don't know this research it was
written well after i left right like
is it the algorithm is it the explore
page is it the people you might know
unit connecting you to you know ideas
that are dangerous like i i really don't
know yeah um
so we'd have to have a much deeper
i think dive to understand where the
blame lies what's very unpleasant to me
to consider now i don't know if this is
true but to consider the very fact that
there might be some complicated games
being played here for example you know
as somebody i really love psychology
i love it enough to know that the field
is pretty broken in the following way
it's very difficult to study human
beings well at scale
because the questions you ask affect the
results you can you can basically get
any results you want and so you have an
internal facebook study that asks some
question of which we don't know the full
details and there's some kind of
analysis but that's just the one little
tiny slice into a some much bigger
picture and so you can have
thousands of employees of facebook one
of them comes out and picks whatever
narrative knowing that they become
famous coupled with the other really
uncomfortable thing
i see in the world which is journalists
seem to understand they get a lot of
click-bait attention from saying
something negative about social networks
certain companies like they even get
some
some click-bait stuff
about tesla or about
especially when it's like when there's a
public famous ceo type of person if they
get a lot of views on the negative not
the positive the positive they'll get i
mean it actually goes to the thing you
were saying before if there's a hot sexy
new product
that's great to look forward to they get
positive on that but absent to product
it's nice to have
uh like the ceo messing up with some
kind of way and so
couple that with the whistleblower and
with the uh this whole dynamic of
journalism and so on you know uh with
social dilemma being a really popular
documentary it's like
all right
my concern is there's deep
flaws in human nature here in terms of
things we need to deal with like the
nature of hate yeah of bullying all
those kinds of things
and then there's people who are trying
to use that
potentially to become famous and make
money off of off of blaming others for
causing more of the problem as opposed
to helping solve the problem so i don't
know what to think i'm not saying this
is like i'm just uncomfortable with i
guess not knowing what to think about
any of this
because a bunch of folks i know that
work at facebook
on the machine learning side so young
lacoon i mean they they're quite upset
by what's happening because there's a
lot of really brilliant good people
inside facebook they're trying to yeah
do good and so like all of us press
diana is one of them and he has an
amazing team of the machine learning
researchers like
he's really upset with the fact that
people don't seem to understand
that this this is not the portrayal does
not represent the the full nature of
efforts that's going on on facebook so i
don't know what to think about that well
you just i think
very helpfully
explained the nuance of the situation
and why it's so hard to understand
but a couple things one is um
i think i i have been surprised at the
scale with which
some
product manager
can do an enormous amount of harm to a
very very large company
by releasing a trove of documents like i
i think i read a couple of them when
they got published and i haven't even
spent any time going deep part of it's
like i don't really feel like reliving a
previous life but um
wow
like talk about challenging the idea of
open culture and like what that does to
facebook internally if facebook was
built like i remember um
like my office
uh
we had this like no visitors rule around
my office because we always had like
confidential stuff up on the walls and
never was super angry because they're
like that goes against our culture of
transparency and like marks in the fish
cube or whatever they call it the
aquarium i think they called it um where
like literally anyone could see what he
was doing at any point and
um
and i don't know i mean other companies
like apple have been
quiet slash lockdown snapchat's the same
way for
a reason and
i don't know what this does to
transparency on the inside of startups
that value that i think that it's a
seminal moment
and you can say well you should have
nothing to hide right but to your point
you can pick out documents that show
anything right
um but i don't know so
what happens to transparency inside of
startups and the culture that
will have
that that startups or companies in the
future will grow like the startup of the
future that becomes the next facebook
would be lockdown and what does that do
yeah right so that's part one
part two
like i i don't think that you could
design
a more like
a
well-orchestrated
handful of events from the like 16
minutes to
um releasing the documents in the way
that they were released at the right
time i
that takes a lot of planning and
partnership and it seems like she has a
partner at some firm right that probably
uh helped a lot with this but
man as at a personal level if you're her
you'd have to really believe in what you
are doing
really believe in it because you are
personally putting your ass on the line
right like
you've got a
very large company
that that doesn't like enemies right um
it takes a lot of guts
uh and
i don't love these conspiracy theories
about like oh she's being financed from
some person or people like i don't love
them because that's like the easy thing
to say
i think the the the occam's razor here
is like someone thought they were doing
something wrong
and was like very very courageous in in
i don't know if courageous is the word
but like so
without getting into like is she a
martyr is she courageous is she right
like let's put that aside for a second
yeah
then there are the documents themselves
they say what they say
to your point
a lot of the things that like people
have been worried about
already in the documents are or they're
already been said externally and
um
i don't know i'm just like i'm i'm
thankful that i am focused on new things
with my life
well let me just say i just think it's a
really hard problem that probably
facebook and twitter are trying to solve
i'm actually just fascinated by how hard
this problem is there are fundamental
issues at facebook in tone and in an
approach of how product gets built and
the objective functions and um
and since people
organizations are not people so yawn and
fair right like there are a lot of
really great people who like literally
just want to push reinforcement learning
forward they literally just want to
teach a robot to touch feel lift right
like
they're not thinking about political
misinformation right yeah but there's a
there's a strong connection between what
funds that research in an enormously
profitable machine
that has trade-offs and
one cannot
one cannot separate the two you are not
completely separate from the system
so
i agree it can feel really frustrating
to feel if you're internally internal
there that you're working on something
completely unrelated and you feel like
your group's good i can understand that
but there's some responsibility still
you have to acknowledge it's like the
ray dalio thing you have to look in the
mirror and see if there's problems and
you have to fix those problems yeah
you